um
a issue i wanted to talk to you about
because i do feel like there
is um
two factions of the defund the police
conversation right um
i think that you know my my mom and my
dad got into a huge argument my my
my parents are older white people my
mom's super hippie she's like
she's really on her [ __ ] the police [ __ ]
and my dad is a little less like
you're crazy right um but i think
that you know i i think that
that at least where i stand on it is
a um i think san francisco just uh
started like you you had posted about it
again
getting a lot of my news from you yeah
san francisco just started it
yeah they just started in situations you
don't need
military you know you don't need armed
police to show up for certain situations
if a kid gets caught shoplifting a candy
bar
at a liquor store there should not be a
uh you know three cop cars to show up
and you i mean at least
you know where i grew up i didn't grow
up in great areas so i know better than
anything
no matter how small or insignificant the
call is it's always three cop cars that
show up
no matter what yeah billy badass
sometimes guns out
and they're gonna make an arrest it's
not gonna be it's not gonna be pleasant
and it could literally be over a candy
bar or a can of soda
or somebody just having a bad day at the
bus stop and someone drives by and sees
like yo this guy's acting crazy at the
bus stop
but what i was going to say was i do
think that it's important that
we reform the police departments that we
have because there's so much bureaucracy
involved
and it's less about doing the right
thing and more about
all of the bureaucracy that comes with a
police department and
the unions and all that and i and i
think that at least where i stand on
defund the police is reallocate a lot of
the sources
in the same way that our um military is
overfunded like
grossly so insanely right yeah like
more than the next 10 countries combined
you know right
and hundreds of billions of dollars are
what you're just wasted
and then the same thing with our police
departments a lot of these police
departments have
equipment that they'll never use you
know what i mean um
but i feel like i'm against just getting
rid of the police but i am for
reallocating funds into the community
from the police and and reforming the
idea of what police
are yeah let me talk let me let me say
something about it first
your dad and most americans
are taught that police keep communities
safe
and i've done studies on this man if you
go to america's
safest cities if you go to america's
safest neighborhoods you can hardly find
a police officer in any of them
they're safe where do you live right now
i live in i live in burbank
if you go to the safest neighborhoods in
all of los
angeles they're not swarming with police
you don't see police precincts you don't
see jails
they are safe because everybody there is
employed
everybody there has jobs health care
education everybody there has resources
they are clean they are well cared for
there there's access to there are no
food deserts there are
wonderful grocery stores there is no
lack
the things that make america's safest
neighborhoods and cities
safe aren't more police yeah and
and that's widely known if you literally
go to the 10 safest
areas of los angeles you could hardly
find the police
and and here and so that's number one
that the safest communities in america
they're safe for very particular reasons
and what we're saying is we want to
duplicate that safety
that kind of safety in other communities
but secondly in los angeles is is
probably the most important
illustration here right now the lapd
takes up over 50 percent of of the
general fund
of all of los angeles over 50 percent of
the budget
if you go to other mega cities around
the country
it tends to be between one and four
percent
in los angeles it's 51
it's so much it's so bloated that that
there's then not
funding for homelessness there's not
funding for substance abuse
and so what they do is in los angeles
and other cities around the country
police are just expected to handle
everything
it doesn't matter if it's substance
abuse or homelessness it doesn't matter
if it's
school truancy in most cities now police
are even the
office handling pet problems and and
missing cats and dogs and it's like
listen
let's remove as much of this as police
from police as we can
number one and then another study showed
and this blew my mind even as somebody
who studies policing this was in the ap
just recently
that in the average major police
department in america
less than one percent of all of their
time
is spent on violent crime the other 99
percent
is spent on traffic tickets is spent on
unarmed non-violent disputes it's spent
on
substance abuse issues it's spent on
homelessness
and what we're saying is when we talk
about defunding the police we're saying
hey let's use money smartly
on substance abuse homelessness and all
of these other issues
and if if they're only actually spending
one percent of their time on violent
crime
let's find a way for them to make that
basically their major thing
that they do and let's put everything
else and assign that
to to social workers to doctors to
nurses
and other civic groups that can handle
it
without shooting and killing somebody in
some cities right now
nearly 60 percent of all people who are
killed by police are having a mental
health crisis
um you know many people are having
either a version of a substance abuse
and a mental health crisis
and it's like listen we have problems
los angeles has problems i live in new
york
new york has problems they're hard
they're complicated
and traditionally police showing up to
the scene with guns
doesn't help any of these problems i
want us to solve them
i'm just saying the nypd and the lapd
don't have a quality track record on
solving the problems of substance abuse
and homelessness
they've been at that stuff for
generations and it's still here
let's actually tackle our hardest
problems
but do it in a way that's bigger than a
gun and a badge
and so we say defund the police we're
saying
if cities say that black lives matter if
cities say that children matter
just make your budget say that and right
now
most city budgets don't show the
priorities they say they
have and we're saying we got to
reconsider how this works